you've been out spotted with not only
looking amazing that was some pretty
handsome eye candy Oh huh oh yeah mr.
robert buckley i'm a huge a zombie fan
really don't talk to me what's going on
you know i'm just feeling really great
right now and super happy i feel very
very very lucky and grateful in my life
right now and that's all that matters a
little blushing going on Leah I don't
know it's just really good bronzer that
was Lea Michele expertly dodging et's
question about her rumored new PO on
Monday we were catching up with a scream
queen star at the Fox up front it's
gonna be in a hospital this year please
tell me we're gonna see the signature
chanel fashion so you know I don't know
I am a how do i phrase this my character
is uniquely placed within the hospital
setting no I guess that's the best way
to put it turning Hester she's just
gonna pop up and the creepiest most
wonderful ways oh yeah I'm very excited
about my story line this season it
mirrors one of my favorite horror films
so that will be interesting if you can
figure it out